we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P
in this voicemail our longtime caller
the Eggman
has a suggestion for me and I want you
to weigh in on his suggestion the Eggman
says David
don't even bother covering the shootings
anymore just don't even bother because
nobody's willing to do anything these
Republicans won't do a damn thing about
it it's just a waste of your breath yes
another one and another one and they're
tragic but what else is there to do
listen to the Eggman say it
hey Dave regarding the shooting at the
Nashville uh Christian private school
three children killed three adults
killed um
don't even discuss it skip right over it
I think that liberals and Democrats are
just wasting our time talking about all
these gun violence and murders and try
to change gun laws it's gonna literally
do nothing I'm listening to the mayor
speak and he's acting like oh now things
are going to change this is the same
thing every time don't waste one second
on this story focus on something that
will actually help we will never change
guns the murders will never stop the
only way they'll stop is when they kill
themselves with their own guns so
it's at a complete waste of time in my
opinion to even discuss these shootings
we should act like they're not even
happening
Shalom what do you think what do you
think does the Eggman have a point I
mean it what he's right about is
it's a circle and it's an endless Circle
and of course this could just be a show
about mass shootings I mean okay
yesterday we had the shooting in
Nashville Tennessee which I covered and
there was a mass shooting in Milwaukee
Wisconsin and then on Sunday there were
mass shootings in Philadelphia
Minneapolis Little Rock Arkansas and
Minden Louisiana and then on Saturday
there were mass shootings in Hempstead
New York Williamston North Carolina
Macon Illinois and Shreveport Louisiana
and then Friday there was another mass
shooting in Shreveport Louisiana so the
the point is every day we could be
talking about these mass shootings
Eggman says even if you don't talk about
them at all or you do talk about them
nothing is going to change
so then what's the point asks the Eggman
I've laid out 10 to 12 bullet points I
talked about it at the top of the show
of of rules and laws and policies that
could be put in place to reduce the
number of mass shootings there's no
willingness whatsoever from Republicans
to Institute even a single one of them
so what is it that we are doing when we
acknowledge these tragedies and of
course we only acknowledge some of them
some of them make the national news and
some of them don't I don't have the
answer quite frankly I'm not pretending
to have the answer but I understand and
sympathize with the eggman's frustration
my question to you
is should these be covered because it
seems strange not to seems strange to
pretend that there is no mass shooting
problem in the United States
at the same time I understand that we've
been covering these things for over a
decade and very little has changed let
me know what you think we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about the new overt
what would we call it recruiting
campaign by Republicans for Senate
candidates that are genuinely Filthy
Rich why is this what they're doing in
what way are they doing it we'll talk
about it secondly is Michelangelo's
David
pornography there are some Florida
parents who say that it is and Italians
are inviting the Florida parents to come
check it out for themselves and then
lastly a TV anchor named Barbie Bassett
has been fired uh taken off air at least
I believe may be fired we'll double
check after quoting Snoop Dogg during a
broadcast and it was a quote of Snoop
Dogg uh should she have been taken off
air what should the repercussions be did
she do anything wrong an uproar about
this and it is becoming another flash
point
in this contrived culture War we will
talk about all sides of it when producer
Pat joins me on today's bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad right let's go
make some money on the bonus show okay
you can sign up at joinpakman.com coupon
code 24 starts now for a discount every
single day after this show there's the
bonus show and we can all be thankful
for that